good morning heck it's tuesday so a few
weeks ago somebody at afc wimbledon the
third tier english football club we
sponsor asked me to make a video message
for the team because the dons have had a
rough go of it and my pep talk did not
like magically turn things around but i
wanted to share some excerpts from it
today because i for one could kind of
use a pep talk when times suck it is
hard to know how they will ever change
my daughter who is eight recently said
when it's winter i feel like it will
never be warm again and then when it's
summer i feel like it will never be cold
again but despite that the seasons go on
changing the way things are is simply
not the way they will always be so
listen i don't know anything about your
problems except that they're as real to
you as mine are to me and that knowing
other people have worse problems doesn't
really help me solve my problems or make
them less real what i do know and have
lately felt quite strongly is that in
the depths of winter you feel like it
will never be spring but before we get
to that i want to say something about
motivation in dark and dreary times in
the first part of my career i was
motivated primarily by resentment and
fear and a little bit of righteous
indignation i wanted to prove to
everyone that they were wrong about me i
wanted to prove to my ex-girlfriend that
she was wrong for dumping me i wanted to
prove to my college creative writing
professor that he was wrong when he said
i wasn't even good enough to take his
class and i wanted to prove to the world
that i could write good books and as
fuel that combination of resentment and
fear and anger worked it burned bright
and allowed me to stay up late at night
writing after i came home from work and
write all weekend and i wrote a book and
it got published and it won awards and
the movie rights sold but it also didn't
work because i was still full of
resentment and anger and fear and
thought i had to be in order to work
also as i became more successful the
pressure increased not just because
there were lots of readers waiting for a
book but also because there were lots of
people whose jobs depended on me
delivering one the thing about
resentment and anger as fuel is that it
does burn bright but it also burns dirty
it created this hole inside of me where
my insecurity and anger lived and grew
this deep well of worry and fear that i
thought i needed in order to write and
every time someone said something nasty
about me or my work online which of
course happened a lot i felt this huge
well of anger and i often lashed out in
ways that helped no one and hurt lots of
people including me it took me a long
time to find a better fuel and i wish i
had a non-cheesy name for it but what
works for me now is love love for
writing itself love for the people who
will read my work and love for the
people i get to work with my editors and
colleagues love is the fuel that burns
both bright and clean and love is not
forged only in the good times it is also
forged in surviving and turning around
the bad times together now of course
when i need to use resentment and anger
i'll use it i'm not above it i'll use
anything that works but i really believe
love can pull us through hard times love
for the games we play and the people we
play them with love for ourselves for
strangers across an ocean for our
teammates and for our families when i
write now i try not to think about what
the story will mean for me but instead
think with hope about what it might mean
for others and when i can do that the
pressure and the fear just melt away it
is winter my friends and it has been
winter for a long time it may be winter
for a while longer
but spring
is coming
hank i'll see you on friday